this morning we're sharing a story that
highlights the strength of one community
despite the ongoing challenges of the
pandemic at 111 years old
lawrence brooks has a unique place among
surviving world war ii veterans
jimmy wack shows us how volunteers
across the state of louisiana stepped up
to help change his life
when he needed a hand
after more than a century you might
think lawrence brooks had gotten just
about
every kind of birthday present
imaginable
[Applause]
[Music]
but as america's oldest known living
world war ii
vet at 111 his birthday this september
came with an
unexpected gift which began with a call
from louisiana governor
john bell edwards right before he hung
up he said to you
let me know if there's anything i can do
for you right and you said
my roof was really good my roof is
leaking this is a lesson
in taking an opportunity right right
yeah
initially being on scene it was a
nightmare i mean there was a vegetation
growing out of the existing
roof there was obviously deficient
framing
kevin griffin and jason engels were part
of a louisiana-based
team tapped by the governor's office to
help lawrence brooks fix shoddy repair
work
done after hurricane katrina
dozens of community carpenter volunteers
answered the call
they fully replaced brook's roof no
questions asked
the governor's words were fix the home
and his roof just like if it was your
own and so that's what we did
born in september of 1909 brooks was
drafted during the second world war
into the then still segregated u.s army
from 1941 to 1945 brooks served overseas
with the predominantly african-american
91st
engineer battalion in places like
australia and new guinea
he took a job as the unit's cook when i
was a kid coming up i used to watch my
my mother used to tell me about show me
different things by cooking
they got us all together and it
definitely sent me to
cooking school with my school for about
six weeks
what did it do for you to be able to
give back to a man like that yeah it it
it kind of makes you re-evaluate
yourself volunteering on something like
this
gives you a purpose they feel good and
with memories of surviving not only the
war
but the spanish flu pandemic of 1918
as well lawrence brooks brings a special
perspective to the current pandemic year
certainly one of the craziest years
you've lived through in your 111 years
what are you thankful for this year
thankful for my life thank you for my
daughter that takes care of me
thank god for entertainment for cbs this
morning
jamie wax new orleans born in 1909
but can you imagine the governor says
anything i can do for you well as a
matter of fact
that's one of those things that people
ask and you don't expect people to
respond
let's have lunch march 32nd but that's
really great there's a lesson in that
yeah it is and kudos to all those people
who came through and put gave him a new
roof